mesdemoiselles messieurs à 18 ans j'ai
quitté ma province bien les styles et
empoigné la vie charles aznavour monte
sur les planches d'un théâtre dès l'âge
de 9 ans il rêvait de devenir comédien
mais c'est la chanson qui domine tout ça
de son vrai nom aznavour yann ses
parents arméniens ont fui le génocide
est immigré en france eux-mêmes des
artistes amateurs ils influencent
grandement le jeune charles né à paris
en 1924 à l'ère du swing il fait ses
débuts au music hall en compagnie du
compositeur français pierre roche
si à ce moment là qu'il fait la
rencontre d'edith piaf
la célèbre chanteuse remarque ses
talents de parolier et le prend sous son
aile
c'est elle qui envoie le dio à montréal
en 1948
charles aznavour à 24 ans ça marchait
partir du premier jour on a eu beaucoup
de chance et les croches lorsqu'on a
commencé au quartier latin construite
oui et puis au bout de quelques jours
on est venu nous chercher pour nous
donner un contrat meilleur bond dans
l'est
celui qui les entraîne dans l'est est
nul autre que jacques normand
l'animateur de cabaret à la mode témoin
rochère d'amour j'ai vu que c'était des
chanteurs populaires chantait du bebop
roche au piano irina brook se tenait
près de micro c'était du tonnerre moi
j'ai dit venez peut voir chez moi à
l'horizon du noir chez moi c'était le
faisan doré et tout de suite nous ont
fait mal à leur séjour de 18 mois au
faisan doré passe à l'histoire mais il
marque aussi la fin du duo charles
aznavour tourner à paris où edith piaf
les encourage à faire carrière solo
l'est la critique est féroce votre voix
n'est pas bonne votre physique n'est pas
vous n'avez pas un physique de star wars
star ce que vous écrivez
c'est marginal à la fin des années 50
aznavour songe même à abandonner quand
la magie opère enfin soir de première à
l'alhambra où il interprète je me voyais
déjà
je me voyais déjà au début des années 60
il connaît aussi son premier grand
succès à l'écran avec le film tirer sur
le pianiste de françois truffaut
c'est la consécration il écrit chante et
joue dans une soixantaine de films
en 1988 il est bouleversé par le
tremblement de terre qui frappe le pays
de ses ancêtres et qui fait cent mille
morts son association à ce niveau pour
l'arménie lui vaut d'être nommé
ambassadeur itinérant auprès de l'unesco
on a mis ça là parce qu'on avait un
tournage c'est ce qui peut voir passer
80 ans l'artiste a toujours l'oeil vif
et beaucoup de verve pas question de
s'arrêter complètement
il affirme qu'il n'est bien que sur
scène on peut dire monsieur lavaud que
les adultes ne sont jamais tout à fait
éternelle avec vous sélectionnez
attendait intérieur je ne fais pas d
azur je fais pas je ne fais pas des
adieux en français jean françois frey
pas des avions français
je fais mes yeux ils ont dieu à des deux
langues je fais les a dû à la langue
anglaise parce qu'il n'a rien mangé plus
en vie d'homme de travailler la langue
toutefois je réapprends moi j'ai pas une
grande mémoire il aime toujours autant
le québec et montréal
denard son fils et le québec ils iront
toujours aussi bien son affection
je suis un paysan un paysan qui a vu
charrues à la main et 7 chez rue c'est
mon destin
le choc est planté dans les scènes de
théâtre et j'ai poussé mon saut en avant
sans me préoccuper de ce qui se passait
autour
il attend paix ni la neige ni le vent ni
la grêle rien et c'est comme ça qu'il
fallait faire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]